I'm old school I'm always like you know
how dare they use that song in a
commercial you know I'm like a rock and
roll purist you know that ozemic that
everyone's taken in Hollywood to stay
skinny but it's really a diabetes drug
they're using the song um oh oh oh it's
magic you know that song by Pilot oh oh
oh it's meant they're like oh it's
ozamic
it is
they can't do that and I get very like I
I sit there on my high horse and I go oh
oh oh I hate this
common side effects are nausea vomiting
diarrhea stomach pain and constipation
some side effects can lead to
dehydration which may worsen kidney
problems I discovered the potential with
ozempic
if eligible you may pay as little as 25
per prescription ask your health care
provider today about once weekly ozempic
every musician
prescription well that's the point
every musician dreams of their music
being used to distract you from a long
list of side effects like I'm so busy
singing
that uh like I didn't even catch that
what did he say at the end he was like
but you could get uh some assistance and
then your prescription would only be 25
per prescription oh I was like that's
not catchy they got that bouncy music
common side effects are nausea vomiting
diarrhea stomach I don't hear nausea
diarrhea
yeah yeah it works
it's like you might your organs out
and they're like oh oh oh I was ampic
and I'm like oh okay that's that's sweet
and they have people dancing as well in
the commercial you know like they're
having a fun time while they're having
this diarrhea on the ozempic yeah on the
ozone commercial you get people dancing
they got the great song the classic song
of zempic
and then you don't you know your
eyeballs might pop out
what'd he just say I was listen I was
listening that catchy tune that's why I
was dancing yeah
your feces may come to life and attack
you what what do you say if you take
ozempic you might eat your foot
did he just no I thought he said you'd
eat your foot it couldn't be
[Music]
foreign